well some women take their placenta sack
and clean their face with it I know some
eat them yeah I know my friend ate her
placenta where's the placenta at that's
what the baby the sack the baby's in so
when they come when the baby come out
it's in a sack you cut the sack and take
the baby out well that stuff they they
say they make soap out of it and makeup
and stuff out of it I don't you can pull
it up a cent say but some people eat it
cuz it's healthy I'm not eating my
insides there's this girl on Tik Tok she
collects her period blood and she sprays
her plants oh my god with period blood
and she has like allegedly she's like oh
I have such a green thumb it's not a
green thumb I actually just spray all my
plants with my period period blood yeah
so she and the blood and the cat plants
like it I don't know oh yeah yeah I
don't yeah yeah that [__] is a vampire
she probably cut that camera off and
lick yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't think
the plant's like that I don't know yeah
you know and some women do art with her
period you know how anyway let's move on
I hate people run around and say oh it's
natural and they just all in the street
smell like a [__] fish sandwich Blood
come on [__] come on you ain't got to
be that [__] natural nobody wants to
smell your ass that is true because if
you think about it it's like I'm
naturally too but I got on a pad [__]
it's like it's the lining of your
endometrium I don't even know what a
[__] IND Demetri is I know a [__] name
Demetrius but to do this
[__] but you're right though I mean here
smelling like ass I mean that is the
worst [__] smell when it sit on you
and dry so bad it's I mean it smell like
so bad it smell like dead people done
die fish done swimmed up and die it's
just yeah I you that I don't ain't
nothing naturally about bleeding in your
[__] underwear and when I see them
women it's all prerogative well [__] do
it in the
house one of your bloody ass out here ho
everybody know you [__]
bleed yeah but can I be honest with you
you know the girl that I'm seeing she
was on her period and I kind of and I
you ate her yeah if it's fresh out the T
it's okay was but if it's sitting there
all day what the [__] you mean it's not
a
beer yeah I did
it P it only smells bad when it's been
sitting in theed it's not [__] Ed it
tastes like pennies it does taste like
pennies it tastes like pennies I bet it
do and penes don't taste good they don't
taste bad I bet you won't swallow a
bucket of [__] pennies that's true
that is true that's true that's true
that's true that's true you're always
smart and you're always yeah you're
right s [__] n yeah I'm sorry as the
period is so [__] nasty you should
unless you're a [__] BL fer or you
need a blood transfusion why the [__]
are you sucking blood out of a
[__] Bobby yeah Bobby why are you
sucking I'll tell you why you know I was
in a sexual mood I don't give a [__] all
right what are you get so angry for it
was in your vagina why are you even
sticking your dick in a bloody [__]
small as as here it just going slip
around slip around you a [__] ain't got
no grip when it's
bleed oh I'm going to die tonight oh my
God no you going to die from that bloody
[__] don't you ever kiss are you are
you if you kissed Miss P Miss Pat are
you eating healthier then I ain't eating
no bloody
[__] I know no I ain't eating healthy
well I don't I want I want you to eat
healthier I [__] this California [__]
I'm going to do what I want to do I know
but I want you because how many people
you know who been eating vegan and
eating green [__] their whole life and
still got canel I'm not going to deprive
myself